une production du studio sfr
nous sans fil le broadcast où on parle
je conte avec nos invités
avec moi
[Musique]
j
y ai mène cette semaine on y mangeait
pas de casque ouais on essaie quelque
chose nouveau de fait mais on essaie de
dire on est certain qu il faut récolter
vos questions si on y répond
ballack ce qui vous me dire qu'ils en
pensent si vous aimez ce bain et non pas
plus
alterner des fois des petits qui n'est
pas son genre c'est le fun parce que ça
me donne l'occasion de parler un peu
plus
tenez un peu plus nous ait pignon aux
plus de souffrir
parce qu'on fait pas tout le temps
connecté parce que si on parle de
physique quantique mais c'est
que ça permet aussi d'aider
aussi bonne façon de dire qu'elle va
passer si vous avez ce s'ouvrait je sais
bien qu'ils bardot et plus de dix
questions ben ali m soit nous envoyer
par email ou les mettre un commentaire
ou tous restent à g ouais
ouais c'est ça mais sinon cher qu'à côté
on a un studio d'enregistrement podcast
en ce moment honnêtement ça bat son
plein le studio de le monde viennent si
le monde arrive juste avec leur contenu
on s'occupe de tout le reste le matériel
technique alliée lloyd impeccable et
infaillible puis puis dans le fond le
monde qui sont heureux tout le monde est
content le service est incroyable ce que
vous avez comme produit est incroyable
la qualité numéro un puis le jeudi
beaucoup le mot incroyable ça me prend
ainsi vraiment à quoi l'événement est
incroyable tchèque mes pieds
on va dire merci aux commanditaires
personnes vous laisse à la conversation
il ya une question dans les chroniques
est on ne peut plus la bombe contre une
cadette épaules nicky une qu'elles
découpent en équipe ouais mais c'est ça
ouais parce que dans une chronique en a
fait honte au rostit un peu le way vous
allez voir là on vous donne un preview
de l'est
mais il y avait une question qui était
destiné - tu étais pas là on peut pas y
répond ce gars là c'est tout cela dans
votre cas cela mais ça sort qu'ils font
là on vous en septembre on se sent on
appris on a pris nos photos la semaine
passée dans une église tout ça la terre
ok bon bain oublier ce que je dis pas
n'importe quel enfant
limites non ça ne soit pas sorti un
accord c'est bon c'est que vous
écouterez la question de temps le
conseil pendant la question est quand
même bon bah oui de toute façon enfin on
va les remercier commence par un
problème au kiwanis bonne école et d'un
jeune question pour toi qu'est-ce qui
est bien rasé pics un bon me couche
à minsk
vous savez c'est ce que la grâce exact
puis on on parle d'un script tout le
temps sont avec nous un commanditaire de
longue date puis il ya une raison pour
cela c'est parce que on adore produits
puis aux autres clairement vous avez
vous aimé leur produit aussi parce
qu'ils veulent continuer à travailler
avec nous
offre une panoplie de produits pour
l'entretien de la retient de de la peau
des coûts et des poils tout ce que vous
avez besoin puis moins honnêtes man
ces deux produits s'ils le shampoing de
en inculpant du wash g j'en ai dans ma
vie parce que j'ai passé ma vie à sentir
le club tout le temps à chaque matin je
me déchire deux clans j'en ai essayé
puis celui le le body wash si le
meilleur que j'essayais points bon il
sans pont hydrate la peau à place de la
sécher a été dévoilée body wash avec le
peu d'alcool s'asséchera potter la
douche des plus secs en rentrant ce ca
idrac ça sent bon
shampoing de rien ne suis pas facile
même où dort pas mono produit par votre
futur indiqué m - oui le coach est vue
comme chez vous si le psy lensois à
l'âme qui flexible kiki mobile pastore
pas un fan des clippers et qu il bouge
pas un fan qui part directement sur les
tatamis autour qui étaient directement
moi jamais eu le chez eux ça vraiment
bien puis dans le rutshuru taquine ce
n'est pas quelqu'un ici on a fait tout
ce qu'on a besoin en eau l'exfoliant
puis on a le gel par âge donc le êtes en
voiture donc m'indiquer pour tout ce qui
est gestion de votre pilosité et de
votre de veau d'or siemens crible que ça
se passe cinéma on a un code promo pour
vous qui le sans filtre pour 20% de
rabais et le shipping gratuit merci mike
hayes merci à vous non pas du tout
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça roule ça roule
c'est quoi
cette affaire la ligne de guides 68 ans
recule quand il a chanté hier
est bien venu changer et nous sans
filtre aujourd'hui si ce qui nous est
nécessaire
ouais très peu de cash tous les deux
parce que why not lorsque wayne gretzky
wine et puis là on est ému on a été
confronté à la notion nicole épaules et
puis ça se peut qu'il ya des problèmes
techniques pendant qu aucun mort ni gré
des syndicats le ccif thann où ceux-ci
aulas sait comment ça marche mais non on
l'apprend par nicole puis on l'oublié
unis comme nous l'apprend après le texte
au fait on
a cessé d'être vous des bons employés
gagnent et et nicole c'est un leurre de
la section entreprenariale
crif a comporté des questions du public
instagram lors sur vos questions
normales et bonnes questions au
téléphone qu'on se lance on se lance en
plus attendre il ya pas vraiment d'ordre
factures dans un autre
oiseau
la première question d'actualité parce
que bon on est maintenant d'élections un
gamin ha ha - pis la question si j'ai pu
noter l'équipe aux élections bon
on sait aussi que la prochaine fois
peut-être notre
de billy bob fait qu est ce qui vous
allez voter à gauche aux prochaines
élections ce qui est une excellente
question des grandes questions puis je
pense que comme point de départ c'est
important de mentionner que
au québec apporte vote pour le parti
conservateur
ce vote à gauche c'est essentiellement
la sécrétion ramener le centre pour ce
qui est le québec mettons le fait qu'on
peut se garder partons avec cette
prémisse lock on est pas mal à gauche la
gauche
moi je ne sais pas encore j'ai pas
encore
chez qu'est ce je n'ai pas encore pris
ma décision en fait ça vient de
commencer je laisse comme le lait la
chance au coureur non sens que je veux
voir jouer suisse puis je veux voter
qu'ils puissent jamais formé aussi sa
source qui propose quelque chose que
l'on fait trop peur j'en fais trop peu
maison parce que je pense a su justement
matin puis
c'est tellement une affaire
identitaire j'ai l'impression pour qui
tu veux te
dit mettons toute ta famille vote
incertain partie ou dans une certaine
direction de tes amis et ta gagne ton
environnement seror quand même que tu
vaux attaque ou complète opposé de ce
puits ou finale
peut-être que se faisait l'exercice de
comme vraiment les voir c'est quoi les
valeurs des participes sais quoi qui
propose
c'est informer vraiment plus
profondément peut-être banques et
finalement l' influence de son
environnement c'est pas nécessairement
ce que toi dividendes qui rejoint
à chaque année je fais genre la boussole
électorale hadouken réflexion à chaque
élection
pitié des fauches comme
je pense que comme j'ai foule affinités
avec un parti ex finalement c'est comme
quand même et je n'en mange plus proche
de tel autre
j'ai l'impression que je peux on est on
vote beaucoup avec un feeling avec
justement le trépied rapidement on tombe
dans
le parti
se veut un verseau ennemis assez parlé
auquel je m'identifie c'est le diable en
personne c'est parce que ça me fait
toujours un pur est passé au final si
tout le monde sauvé et quelques
exceptions qui sont aux lourdes
séquelles que vraiment cruauté c'est ce
soir que des exceptions mais la pause
monde qui sont le säntis pendjab facile
puis le font parce qu'ils y ont des
idées aux publicités qui veulent les
portes et puis valjas
le mieux pour le québec pour leur vision
de ce qui ce qui est le bon pour le
québec l'a dit
si tu penses que un parti que ces genres
le diable en personne
t'as pas compris je trompe le complexe
est pas mal et ça devient vraiment
justement l'idéologique de détester à
partie puis tu votes pour un pilotage à
la pire chose de l'univers c'est comme
premièrement
les différends sont souvent même pas son
minois jacques souvent même les
différences son jardin juste la façon de
phrase est une idée c'est souvent tout
le monde veut la même chose à la fin de
l'histoire mais c'est de la façon de s'y
rendre qui différencie avec genre si tu
pense vraiment qu'il ya un parti qui les
good guys me martin et bas de gamme par
avec le concept du titre on sait si ça
n'est pas tellement ton cercle pour
sortir sans une certaine bulle mettons
que québec solidaire ça peut être les
sauveurs du monde puis la caq c'est la
pire abomination c'est plus de change de
bull pi québec solidaire ces genres une
gamme des pelleteuses nuage données du
monde font n'importe quoi et qu'y qui
ont la pensée magique qui genre la caq
ces genres fois qu'ils aient gens
restent jardin c'est qu'ils final le ccc
n'y a eu ni la haute lesse et quand même
fêté ses 10 ans hier fethi jeu paul
informe toi informe toi si franck prend
une décision éclairée dati dit on on est
on est de retour on a pris une petite
pause le souhaite je marchais pas fait
que le cadre est posé sur moi on se pose
les droits des doigts mais ouais c'est
ça ce que je disais avant ça c'était que
ça demande du travail et prendre un
choix éclairé parce que
comme je disais tout les toutes les
parties depuis le début de la campagne
ça fait une semaine ont fait des
annonces d'innombrables annonce puis
d'être capable de les écouter chacune
d'elles comprendre leurs spécificités
pis les analyser selon non seulement ce
que toi tu veux pour ta propre vie mais
ce qu'est ce que tu veux aussi pour
collectivement de cigares maintenant
l'exemple de québec solidaire qui était
de passage à québec qui ont annoncé
leurs plans pour le réseau de transport
au chemin de son parler du
du l'autoroute qui passerait par la
parole et l'île d'orléans de la québec
pour faire un même point tunnel
l'austérité c'est le plat conservateurs
c'est un autoroute qui passerait
directement jusqu'à lévis et puis le
québec solidaire ont planifions prêts
ont présenté leurs plantes pilote une
analyse tu le vois ses côtés puis il ya
eu
le premier abord main de fer mais si
c'est sûr goutte c'est une idée parfaite
dans le fond plat presse revient plus à
dormir dans les prochaines semaines on
va essayer de faire l'exercice ici au
sans filtre vient l'analyse des comment
ça marche c'est comment qu'on sera
jusqu'à cette idée là mais bref faire
tout seul mandat un travail vraiment en
profondeur c'est pas tout le monde qui
prêt à mettre 7 en ressources et des
outils comme la boussole électorale ça
permet au moins de temps en ligne et un
petit peu plus puis pour revenir à la
question initiale de
répondre dispo m'occupe est-ce que je
vais voter à gauche moi je pense c'est
la première fois de ma vie ben en fait
mon vote est encore hindi elle vraiment
plus probablement plus qu'à n'importe
quelle élection
vraiment habituellement je votais à
gauche particulièrement les deux
dernières élections j'ai voté québec
solidaire
mais là pour la première fois de ma vie
je pense que je suis comme ambiguë un
peu dans wii ce que j'aimerais que la
société a et parce que
j'ai l'impression puis peut-être que
c'est juste une mauvaise impression pour
que les prochaines semaines vont me le
discuter mais j'ai l'impression que pour
avoir des idées progressistes
puis pour avoir les moyens de ses
ambitions de faire des gros changement
social comme par exemple québec
solidaire peut le proposer j'ai
l'impression qu'il faut avoir une
société en santé
puis avec les dernières années j'ai
comme l'impression qu'ils ont on a
besoin d'un peu de stabilité avant des
gros projets tic fait que j'ai comme le
feeling que d'essayer d'aller chercher
ce stabilité là avant de leur dire
qu'ils on est solides pour faire des
gros projets d'infrastructures mais
infrastructures masse et les trois
dernières années ont été absolument
frivole tous les points de vue là je
pense que c'était autant économiquement
que socialement pas en santé du
questionnement
personnel
fait m'évader india encore c'est pas dit
que je voudrais pas encore une fois pour
québec solidaire mais c'est pas dit non
plus que je continuerai pas avec la
caisse pas dit on à ses clients de 10
produits non plus qu'elle ne voterait
pas pour le seul parti
indépendantiste
qui se présentent et fac est mon vote
est difficilement s'est dit que je vois
très probalement pas conservateurs
voient ça c'est pourtant là dessus s'est
probablement dit quand je dis aucun
mauvais parti c'est comme c'est vrai
sauf
sauf pour les maçons parce que pour
revenir si j'écoutais l'entrevue de
mounir le maire de laval avec éric
duhaime - puis ce test il pas mourir
éric duhaime le camp y est assis devant
quelqu'un qui peut le challenge est
comme mounir pouvait le challenge et il
vient nuancer
soudainement savait pas qui part
soudainement ils viennent nuancer puis
l'oeil comme ces idées font plus de
sentiments genre c'est seulement parce
que lui et paniers en les plus extrêmes
votre pour lui tu fait qu'il faut qu'ils
soient capables de garder et aux autres
qui leur parlait déjà quand même intense
mais en même temps faut quand même que
tout ce bois nuancé pigeât tapella la
lame à la masse les mettons pas cru
quand même qu'ils jouent à mettre de
l'eau dans son vin
parce que je pense qu'en faisant ça paie
en voulant appelé à
ce groupe le plus radical
il peut perdre il va gagner des votes
avec cette tranche là mais j'ai aussi
l'impression qu'il va perdre des votes
mais dont moi j'arrive là je me dis ok
le système de santé à deux vitesses avec
un système privé avec un party privé je
trouve que c'est une bonne idée puis lui
c'est une idée qui porte mais jamais je
vais m'autoriser à voter pour concert
pour pour son parti par contre les néo
nazis à cause de l'inertie pour lui
c'est ça c'est ça fait qu'autant il va
chercher les néonazis qui votent pour
lui le tir bon exagération quand même le
met mais autant il perd des gens comme
moitié qui pourrait potentiellement
trouver des idées conservatrices
intéressante bref
pour répondre à ces questions j'ai voté
contre
j'ai voté québec soldats dans les
dernières élections
pitié à ce moment à moins qu'à et un
revirement incroyable
on s'est pas mal qui veut boire puis qui
majore match mais a quand même avec une
forte est fortement forte avance et
puis je trouve qu'ils qu'avec soldats
quand même c'est un bon parti à être
dans l'opposition officielle toi parce
que tu es partie des grâces des eaux
puis de grands principes pigeât
cellphone avoir ce com qui vient
équilibrer un anticipe le gestionnaire
puis de joueur de bochum line c'est ça
qui est fort possiblement que ça va
aller vers le haut mais on verra dit
ouais encore inédit excité c'est la
question numéro 1 - ouais on sent qu'une
bande sujet question numéro deux griefs
de joséphine tremblay génome entier pour
faire
un lien joker si vous vous entendez
votre question certains de vous réclamer
de votre question vous fait un
commentaire de ses magasins ses moyens
de vous réclamer de votre question vous
vous entraînez combien de slash jours
par semaine
et que vous exposez vos yeux
moi je m'entraîne moi j'ai un genre de
règles non écrites qui
que j'essaie de m'entraîner
à chaque jour mais sauf que ça donne
vraiment un peu ouais pis au final ça ça
fait que je m'entraîne tatin
4,5 fois semaine peut-être 4.5 mettons
un moyen
qui calment en train de montrer une
hausse jusqu'à 1 400 mm sur ce je vous
creuser les trous noirs ou soit je veux
courir 10 km un brin sensiblement une
samba sow c'est quand même quand même
bon puis au final
c
c'est pas tant que ça c'est vraiment pas
donc c'est pas beaucoup de temps garde
face à dijon je t'aime et on je prédis
intime et on a eu pas de mon l'accusent
de reims je m'entraîne cinq fois semaine
fraîche
ça reste toujours bien ça car ça mais
c'est rien c'est rien c'est
le monde qui perd c'est normal
tu pozza fois plus en plus et ça c'est
sa girlfriend de comme un hobby le genre
du fait du lavage 5h semences pas une
corvée qui fait 5h semaine dès ce moment
ils sont quelque chose que tu aimes 115
mn à faire le coup de tête avec ces
mêmes pas beaucoup le temps c'est pas
assez maintenant - fax et si ce n'était
pas un chèque en plus le titre est assez
pour être faible krismenn 5 sylvain
massé en fait 1 5 fois ducrocq cette
semaine même temps chef loin même que ce
même que genre tu peux pas vraiment en
faire plus que ce nom parce que c'est ça
parce qu'il veut mais tu peux pas tu
peux pas est-ce qu'on va falloir que je
prenne s'appelle le scud mon nom n'est
pas tout
oui le
climat
y est ce
que tu l'as où tu vas te convenait
9h30 chez vous
yes 9h30 je suis la main
yes salut m'en
excuse moi j'attendais ce demain je veux
tester la saveur de hyères puis il me
fait kiffer même quand c'est meilleur je
descendais genre pour sont un peu
mais non c'est 5 armand nicolas reprend
excuse moi il n'y a plus rien qui va me
déranger men fait sinon mes cinq heures
par semaine c'est beaucoup mais
l'entraînement l'entraînement ouais
c'est ça puis c'est ce que tu dis est 4
à 5 fois de crosse par semaine même que
prend la clé les pros crossfit or ils
font 4 à 5 fois de gracieux par semaine
puis du cross training autour de lui
quand tu peux vraiment faire plus que
cela comme un genre de 2,3 fois plus de
la course points clés mais trois quatre
cinq fois c'est même si beaucoup le
métier mais ton temps tu vois trois fois
lundi mercredi vendredi et que les
autres journées de faire une petite
course ont intrigué plus ras la glace et
était vraiment et en voiture dans
business maison maison puis fax et c'est
au final c'est pas tant de temps que
faut juste que tu trouves une manière de
tan tan nara infos sur le plein field et
planifie et ça arrive pas de ce
mois monsieur tu as plus que seulement
je suis
je dois faire à peu près
en ce moment le peut-être moins six
semaines parce que ma course et dans une
semaine et demie mais georges leurs
efforts dans douze et quinze heures par
semaine m puis les plus grosses semaines
15 en montant le mais encore le tir
d'un programme où j'aime vraiment c'est
allez mettons le week end allait courir
pendant six heures j'adore faire ce
genre c'est une des choses que j'aime le
plus fort
dans le bois le 6 et le 10 mai
mais encore le tir qualité ou secondaire
5 même après seulement ça continue et
plus tard le mais
c'est ouais on s'entraînait 20 heures
par semaine comme si c'était un pet on
se rendait pas compte à quel point c'est
beaucoup de voix c'est beaucoup c'est
ouais
pyjama ma femme et émettant 15 lycées au
monde on va s'entraîner deux fois
semaine une fois deux heures plus de
lyme blues la muscu l'on sait que mais
comment tu fais et genre comme en phase
iib mais aussi comment il faisait pour
avoir la motivation mais tombe si comme
c'était pas une question de motivation
c'était ce qu'on faisait c'était ce
qu'on fait on se levait pour le faisait
parce que
c'était seconde c'est comme t1 mais
comment turc a travaillé 40 rock où se
trouve la motivation avec 40 heures
c'est pas une question motivation c'est
cet avis que le travail de cet avis et
dalé et entraîner bien c'est parce que
tu organises ton truc autour de titres
tout d'organiser sa vie pour être
capable de refaire
non c'est ça exactement entier mois
maintenant mais mes longues sorties
mais longues sorties du week end et ma
vie planifié aux autres c'est ça ton
activité là ma blonde a le sien
maintenant je dis j'aurais le comme
samedi comme la samedi dans deux jours
j'agis ma dernière sortie avant l'été
achat fort comme ce long week-end ça
fait deux semaines grossit pas vu ce
week end qu'on peut se passer quand même
ça va être au tour de ceux ci ont tous
les flamands on va sortir de montréal on
va aller quelque part pour faire ce pour
paraître longues sorties là parce que
c'est ça la vie que suis imposé si je
manquais de temps pour faire du sport
je serai pas bien c'est si jamais
j'arrive c'est quand même là j'ai juste
pas le temps de montrer ça oblige - avec
fait coincer sa réponse puis c'est
nécessaire mais c'était nécessaire mais
dis moi ce que j'ai sûrement déjà dispo
casse aussi métier je vois tout de suite
la différence mettons que ça fait une
couple de jours que maintenant que je me
suis entraîné parce que le troll à
prolonger le métro dans le gym est un
qui veut que tout soit des raisons je
fais pas ça par rmn dans
darmon jean-paul de stress que l'on
ressent en vente apparaît dans mon
humeur ça n'a rien d'un mot comme ans
que je suis à gré avec la monte à paris
comment je me sens bien confiance en moi
en titre subit
tout des affaires fois king importante
puis des fois je me demande déjà si je
m'entraînais pas 0 je repars une
personne non je trais une autre personne
d'en créer une autre personnalité
puis je retiens c'est à ce point là
lorsqu'il voit tant
pis mais ton
si j'ai des amis l'exploit gueule avec
et puis le jeu peu c'est pas une
solution miracle non plus mais trim et
on
sait que j'ai des amis qui me disent ah
je suis raciste en 6 ou jugea jeu
l'anxiété pour 6 pour ceux où c'est un
sculpteur faux sang si j'ai moins
confiance en moi où je suis dans ma
femme
ne dit pas fait ce pas parce que ça
c'est pas genre il ya pas de miracle
d'avis mais se sait ce qui est le plus
proche c'est une certitude
saïda christophe ça va définitivement
pas nui
maintenant que 99 9% de chances que ça
aille puis 0 % de chances que ça nuit en
fête et un bombe est quand même
c'est clair c'est que là vraiment c'est
toi tu le site de l'ancien domaine
artistique aussi mais moi je moi aussi
je connais tu m'emmènes qui je sais pas
dans leur vie faire du sport
oui
on
n'a même pas comprendre ce parce que du
plus loin que je me rappelle mes tantes
et j'ai commencé à manger aussi
longtemps je me souviens des c'est vrai
à cinq a commencé contre natation qui
s'est illustrée le samedi matin procès
le samedi dimanche matin capa se
trouvent 4 5 6 7 8 fois très longtemps
plus pis justement anti je me suis un
peu clairement d'une période de ma vie
où est ce que je m'entraînais pas c'est
juste comme normal pis faut le faire
mais c'est celui de plein de gens qui
s'est fait passer leur vie mais je me
suis ok
ça peut bénéficier tout le monde
définitivement hier c'est la question
numéro 2 ouais
c'est le fonctionné je me suis bien oui
c'est l'fun s'en parle après la fac et
qu'on avait parlé faut plus garde pas
plus vous vieillissez ça si on va la vie
plus on ne parle un peu avec un mode
cendres xpan son père ben non pas parce
qu'ils créent et de l'anxiété maintenant
avec le fait de vieillir
moi je trouve que j'ai à alger par
demain qui est enfin on dirait
pour
tout ce que je
m'étends en ce moment je suis comme dans
une page web qu avec la cave est aussi
sur ce après dilemme était maintenant il
ya
plein d'endroits dans le monde que
j'aimerais voir mon nom je prends un
exemple clichés des voyages il ya
vraiment plein à faire dans le monde que
j'aimerais voir au tir
puis l'a emmené quantique intervenants
différents ennemis
juge de faire le tour du monde ces
endroits là que je rêve de peut-être
voir je voulais voir entier mais la
mettons que c'était sur un petit fils
calcules tu dis
admettons que toulouse dans son budget
le ski pour mon cas actuellement mais
donc telle autre budget
combien de voyages
genre alive tianjin mais combien le
voyage
intéressant tu peux faire par année et
donc tu dis là pour prendre la peine de
rendre découvrir une place
deux à trois semaines mais tant qu homme
du monde un pays c'est deux à trois
semaines
tu peux faire sur une fois par année une
fois ci mon argent vrai voyage ces
métaux ce qu'on a fait à taïwan déjà
longtemps ça fait six ans qu'on est à la
pointe qui 5 1 c'est dans trois semaines
puis honnêtement ça aurait été moins que
sa soeur était trop court je pense le
tient qu'un voyage comme cela
préparation monétairement ce que ça
représente faut que tu tapes sound est
en vente et en vacances tu le fais une
fois dans l'année max abbas une fois à
chaque deux agents plus grand sérieux
quelqu'un qui voyage beaucoup c'est ce
exact plus tu commences à faire le
calcul que tu dis chrysler maintenant
j'ai 31 des places dans le monde que
j'aimerais partir trois semaines que
l'on a fait à taïwan il y en a à
l'infini plus te parle juste de voyage
le mieux en à l'infini humaine que je
que j'aimerais aller voir puis pas que
j'aimerais aller voir quand j'ai 55 ans
que j'aimerais aller voir maintenant
puis surfer puis j'en retire des
exemples mais faire un est-il rail qui
était vivre ma trentaine ailleurs et
puis là on dirait que j'arrive même
puisqu'une fois que j'ai pu le temps ou
si georges comme confronté à l'idée que
crêchois manqué de temps ça c'est pour
les voyages mais tant qu il extrapole à
ses pleins d'autres aspects de ma vie
d'enfant j'enrage j'aimerais se
sait d'ors just menace d'andré qui
tendrait que j'ai
je peux plus être
top niveau c'est derrière moi je
redevenais élite c'est l'âge écouter le
podcast de mathieu blanchard le trottoir
être et les transports me compétitionner
au met au monde s'est terminée plus tard
ivre plus jamais le message est très
clair et ferme j'ai même pensé même pas
la moitié encore là mais c'est terminé
pour cette porte là est déjà derrière
moi plus tu vois toutes les autres
portes qui éventuellement pour se fermer
ouais genre
forte même si le stock tous ces facteurs
cepici
quelqu'un qui écoute et l'autre a quitté
cet été à 20 ans je pense que tout est
possible tu es dans l'idée que tout est
possible pitot comme je t'aime comme tu
disais tout est devant moi puis jeu pour
faire ce saut sociaux puis à 30 ans le
ton
c'est comme se désistant poterne
athlètes professionnels alors de 30 ans
toujours là mais tu seras jamais je ne
serai jamais
qui
ces facteurs mais moi tu vois
ça m'angoissait plus à 25 à 30 ans en
ski et maintenir mettons à 30 ans c'est
comme d'avoir un point qui se dit ok ben
ma vie c'est
sa voix ressemble à ce que ted avoir une
coupe de surprise le chemin pink
d'affaires meja
six mois puis vous ce que je fais pili
talent que j'ai développés pillent un
ananas qui
s'abat à 20 ans et que moi je te faire
ça mais je tenais à faire ce petit jeu
tout vive bizarre comme clamant non mais
moi j'ai quand même de plus en plus dans
l'acceptation de plus le temps passe
justement c'est plus le staff a fait le
trou
pillet avant ça m'angoissait groupe
chaque anniversaire de genre d'arnaqué
si le g20 et ayant un pied à 21 lui
avait fait cela je le comparais faut le
placer comme
mais
dans l'acceptation que ma vie c'est ce
même
drapeau
la drive que j'avais qui est finalement
ses portes sont fermées puisse rouvrir
ont porté ce serait d'ailleurs sur
ces sites off mais
sylvain la fac qui se passe qu'est
quelques risques et que j'essaie quand
même puisque c'est ben laden est
ok exc
je comprends je comprends mais on dirait
que
tu parles feeling qui est vraiment
inquiétant pour lyon la fin août eu le
feeling est comme
thème commun peut arriver à
que comme ce qui te reste à faire le
fond de moi la passe a rejoint
soumettons ma part c'est
manquer de
makita
parce que je t'ai objets travailler
comme des français
puis
mettons j'ai choisi de faire de la
musique dans vie je vous dise par un
podcast
c'est mettons ma priorité clairement
numéro un l'an viii c'était pas d'être
millionnaire
puisse aller toujours possible celle de
même mais pitié mettons moi j'ai
commencé à travailler tout le dans ma
vie des professionnels je ne travaille
beaucoup en plus du coup le psychiatre
de l'université pilule faute de contrat
musique jeter comme à 21h et comme ces
jeux se cache l'un à l'impôt pour un
gars de 21 ans maintenant que les amis
encore aux études et en outre fait
dépasser
200 pièces par guy depuis puis tu fais
de l'argent jeté par la fenêtre par
semaine que ce mai
puis le 10 points puisque je continue là
dedans sauf que c'est le plateau le
plafond a fait il faut que tu le panier
quand tu es quand il fait juste de faire
des shows pétain et guitariste et
engagera jamais dit mais le pillage par
sword non pas qu'il ait le plafond pitt
et moi ce
rythme de vie le niveau de vie le me
conviendrait bien glacé pas besoin
d'avoir
une lamborghini oasis je n'ai aucun
intérêt pour ce mais le rapport à ce
moment c'est comme québec le taux est
éventuellement et le tarp avance pigeât
commence à penser juste une famille
l'anapi le sait comme au hockey si j'ai
une femme et ils ont juste moi qui
dépendent exact mon niveau de vie que
j'avais cac s'était juste mes dépenses à
moi en prenant suffisant mais l'état
peut si j'ai les cours de soccer paix
les cours de rock et piles et
le
piano puis à davos qui est-ce qui mène
pige à toutes les dépenses le nourrir
c'était c'est bush note le seco motoaki
le calcul qui marchent pas
[ __ ] moi de la faire qui fonctionne
moi c'est seul apparemment passé comme
le travail à côté on dit ci dessus pour
ceux qui travaillent à côté lorsque
charles tu t'es dit mettons
faut que je dise où et à tout parce que
j'arrive pas cette année je me suis un
peu digéré
je me suis je me suis vraiment à côté
niveau et travaille je travaille autant
encore à ce jour le jour on parle en ce
moment le grand terrain côté que jamais
travailler autant on reste année qui en
même temps je me dis bastien quoi donner
des piges à jeu permettant un peu de
côté parce que leur soit moi j'ai pas
vraiment de dépenses que je me foutais
justement pour avoir mis un coussin plus
tard mais
même à fabre le temps
cegertec ma blonde qui a été dit
sur les enfants pitt rôle de ma femme
c'est leur poule ouais poteau électrique
ce l'équation et nous mettons le recul
et c'est la solution parce qu'il aimait
tant justement tu mets ton être un
guitariste s'est impliqué très arty
les à l'hôtesse
qui vous étiez quand un mâle bp après
sur le lendemain mme gauthier à gaspésie
berval gaspé gaspé
roberval gaspé 2000 kilomètres pour
aller jouer une place
dans notre élection rendue à bali mais
c'est en italie même quatre fois en
gaspésie joyal et notre foi en septembre
deux fois lac saint jean chibougamau
c'est fou la route le temps comme peace
is a fact 18 12 manches souvent partie
blessés comme que ça marchera plus ça
marche réputé fait klaus et cela passait
comme c'est quoi comment
fabre arrivé bâton pour avoir
le temps à donner parce que sam moi ça
me dérange pas travailler 70 heures
samedi c'est ce sens à masseube et en ce
moment
ça me dérange pas tant mais
éventuellement si j'ai envie de voir mes
enfants me dis que j'ai pas encore mais
si j'en ai jeté voient leurs pas et moi
j'ai envie de les voir j'ai envie
d'avoir du temps pour veiller à ce que
j'aime ce travail et je ne sommes à dieu
mais il faut vivre aussi un peu juste ça
m'a fait aimer ton
le groupe des semaines celle et finira
et mon nom
avec le cpie c'était comme une finira
non-officiel c'était jean ray chez ma
tante piste et comment nous autres pays
c'était pas l'église est pas prête pour
ce fait une cérémonie en nous aux
pièces uniques ou des cousines oncles
tantes s'affaisser enfin vous avez vu
mais tant
pis si ça demande que j'ai envie d'avoir
l'amm avis déplacé comme mais qui prend
aucun temps tu peux pas c'est si je peux
poser les termes non merci tu fais le
choix de jeux comme world et ce choix
est un choix toujours c'est toujours un
joint mettez
ça m'a quand même fait de quoi déjà fait
état peu le
entretiennent un minimum genre des
relations de voir des frères soeurs
parents ne veut entendre cousin je veux
garder mon avis pc
puis tiens justement la mort d'un proche
ça fait réaliser que comme à quel point
c'est important la famille mes tempes
des vendanges a profité comme à qui ils
étaient radicalement déconnecté des gens
de tuer le type mettant mon ombre mais
si comme les ananas années j'aurais pu
voir blues un joli but un petit parti un
mois plus tard les choses en perspective
c'est clair mais c'est après ce
triste c'est quoi la solution
c'est parce que maintenant date mais là
je te promets à toi mais la pose à moi
aussi le titre ça c'est quoi
c'est comment entre voile
avoir plus de temps mais pouvoir aussi
subi écrite de vicky souvenirs en
famille mais
comment tu fais
pour à l'amorcé de
réorienter un peu mon truc là parce que
tu sais mais moins faire le show peut
plus produire méditer ce que je m'étais
dit
parce qu' aimer ton
je m'étais dit à qui cette année je te
mangerais plus de chez plus de des
musées que ces méthodes de composition
pour et des contres de soin de publier
des trucs qui fait que je prête je peux
aller travailler
ne fasse un bon mix et mixer les albums
mais je peux aller travailler au bureau
mais revenir le soir spectable ont
touché tout le jam
qui s'il ya moins de perte de temps que
faire douze heures de route pour la paix
je m'étais dit québec toutes ces choses
là que je faisais avant
je suis norme nfc comme coup plus juste
oui à des affaires que je peux pas dire
non c'est l'enfer vraiment noire qui l'a
finalement
si mettons j'ai aussi montré chaud des
antennes tout
mis la pression mais je souhaite
proposer des kits est out montraient
choqués je m'étais dit elle je peux pas
dire non à la même situation
mais le faux curé
c'est vraiment bon signe permettant aux
c'est encore autre chose plus
ces malades ouais c'est un signe fort et
se met tout le temps seul cissé l'offre
et la demande menti quand ces symptômes
ne mettons je serais pour des pubs le
thé c'est nous qui gérons les peuples
pour pour sexe oral ccsf qu'ils allaient
peu pitié juste les peuples amis le
podcast comme tellement de succès qu
elle s est convaincu main le prix des
pubs c'est son fils jamal le dire le
prix des pubs à certaines compagnies
parce que son cri semaines semble c
genre ça représente un bon coup dans ton
dans ton cash flow le tpn publ sur sur
se placer comme le monde font mais ok je
suis inquiet mais le on ne place depuis
peu il ya place pour les fêtes gens
s'étaient moqués
et encore et encore une
fois c'est bon signe effectivement ça
ouais mais colman scellé par mail et bon
port
après sauter une question pied parce que
ça fait un lien qui se disaient pas ce
qui les gêne parler un peu de ce que je
faisais dans la ville noire ils
demandent qui est qui qui déplut slick
les cages world fans ça va tout remettre
en cause
ptc sauf moi rire fit cadeau vous n'êtes
pas tout là depuis l'épisode 11
depuis le début mais le gamin tantôt
chaleur thierry il m'avait nous ont
écrit pour parce qu'il veut ce lensois
podcasts ou le jazz et pour avoir des
conseils plus choisis chauffer que jacky
jeudi george hill auteur que j'adore je
prends tout mais appelle encore tout le
temps sinon jour tu son téléphone au
même à ces dates ont dit banco et louis
puig est 18 heures puis ian ritchie
veulent ils travaillent beaucoup de jeu
au pied je suis ancien podcast sur le
sport pis il m'a dit mais j'écoute il ya
18 maintenant et j'ai commencé à créer
votre podcast à 14 octobre imagine même
à 14 ans fait genre car nous on a reçus
lisant puis james hyndman dans la
cuisine pour le premier podcast il y
avait 14 18 quand je parle au téléphone
genre et adultes en a douze des tués
étaient des gens qui gênent quand même
et si c'est lui je suis pour son
parler vraiment comme deux adultes
peuvent se jase il y avait quatorze
cantons a commencé assez bizarre c'est
fou c'est parce qu'un dossier sensible à
ma villa 4-1 aujourd'hui et les
personnes
essentiellement plus une coupe
d'expérience d'expérience
mais en 14-18
change au conflit petit chat non
seulement au complet change au complet
quatre fois mais
c'était fou mais merde que un bref mais
il y aura quand même pas mal mais pour
ceux qui
pensent qu'il faut que pour pour mettons
site écouter écouter les deux cent dix
épisodes sans fil podcast tk pas d'avoir
un casse tête assez précis maintenant de
qui on est
dans une pièce ici une pièce la pièce la
pièce le peloton comme le portrait
complet de disques ont offert à nos vies
bref la question c'était à part si c'est
fait
je peux résumer rapidement lassé mais
moi ça fait depuis
et plus elles mêmes quand je pense à
ceux
le terme et on le sait la rentrée
quand je rentre aux cégeps développe 14
en 2008 ce s'est fait rentrer aussi je
rentre au cégep steve locke 14 ça me
fait flipper mais je comprends pas mais
bref
j'utilise expédia musique dans la vie je
commande des artistes fait de la tournée
puis je fais du mixage réalisation de
nanas qui
de cet été je joue beaucoup avec
jonathan roy je me crois car ayant
droits les qui je travaillais ce puis
tant qu'à faire je réponde aux questions
d'après ce que je vais te lancer la
balle les questions 7,2 où l'on peut
entendre tamisée et ma musique mettons
gpo ce top 12 les plantes dans spotify
soir un trouble mais bientôt avoir des
dj sets parce que dominique ans est bon
en électro wells avant de composer la
musique d'un podcast sans lien pilule je
m'amuse avec les claviers qui s'était
sans
doute de futurs
mais
c'est ce que vous allez retrouver parce
que moi j'ai pas sensé musique à mon
propre nom
mais mettons j'étais artiste et que j'ai
travaillé que je sois mixer leurs albums
où j'ai réalisé leur album ça faisait
kate on a travaillé l'étonnant sans les
arrangements tout le processus de de
tout le processus de répartir avec une
toune qui juste piano voix ou guy de
woippy avoir un album qui finit kientéga
fakih est un projet en fait le projet
que je sais que je peux travailler je
supplie fia c'est l'album de ariane
leroy que si vous l'écoutez quelque
chose que j'ai faite à l'écouté ce
médium plaisir mettez un plaisir c'est
normal c'est vraiment bon ce projet là
parce que si vous connaissez pas aller
l'écouter le match je fais c'est
vraiment rapide si vous avez la chance
de voir aussi le show live jeux d'argent
noir je pense qu'il reste des tournées
ont fait encore plus chaud on fait aussi
un show nationale à montréal le bacille
21 octobre puis un show où pend thomas
québécois comme des choses peu plus
spécial c'est vraiment hâte puis sabra
au sang chaud
d'abord c'est cool séverac
qui oscille autour écouter et un album
que j'ai travaillé avec mon ex le lian
puis c'était 2018-2019 qu'on a ce
qui est sous c'est sûrement faire du
buzz doit quoi vraiment je redoutais ce
mode objets crise de nom de l'album
showtime
c'est vrai
qu'on avait travaillé vraiment fort
pillet
s'est vraiment c'est vraiment différent
si jean r'n'b pas moins
hardis indie rock et pop le fait que
c'est peut-être peut-être qu'un jour tu
sois en album peut-être que j'aurais
aimé jouer
tph qu'est-ce que dans la caisse fait
dans la vie à part le site us f moi je
fais
des entrepreneurs
le studio s'est aucunement par ce
montant mais sinon la majorité de mon
temps à part dans le studio je la mets
dans ma compagnie pika que vous
connaissez peut-être que j'avais déjà
entendus par les suppléments du port
puis ça me demande beaucoup de temps ce
que j'apprends moustoir c'est ça c'est
vraiment une star la plus sexy carrément
sur carrément ce puits avec un bon
succès fait que oui sinon je m'entraîne
je suis c'est à peu près maintenant si
je faisais mon oreille c'est
probablement comme
j'ai envie de dire 40-40 maintenant 40 %
studio 40% et puis que vaille pour ses
entraînements dans sa main sur mon
horaire mais si je brigue donne mon 100
% d'occupation
ou est-ce que je peux chez nous en train
de chile me suis rarement à ces jours ci
je suis rarement en train de toucher des
gens de rien je gagne plus j'ai comme
tout le temps
une bonne nouvelle je m'ennuie paul
ouais c'est ça mais ouais ça fait
cool c'est la question qu'est ce qu'on
fait six
rapports c'est quoi ta peau c'est quoi
la vision 5 10 ans dissuasif ça fait un
bon fond avec cette question là on en a
parlé l'autre fois ensemble pour 5 10 en
a sûrement mais dans l'immédiat peut pas
dans l'immédiat mais justement plus que
d'années comme d'année puis
il ya beaucoup de points
d'interrogations on dirait dunkerque en
jeu flash faurie parce qu'il ya
plusieurs points et mettons plus on va
peut-être en profiter pour faire du
moins j'en profite pour donner mon
opinion sur genre les podcasts la
direction que ça s'en prendre
au québec et un boom de podcasts dans
les derniers
trois ans dont la bande et mieux
rapidement accéléré ce
jusqu'à un point où est ce que pour la
quantité d'auditeurs
il y avait une saturation
assez clair il ya vraiment beaucoup de
podcasts pour le nombre d'auditeurs
un
fake là je pense qu'on a comme un peu
plafonner le nombre de podcasts
grand public disons cela comme ça parce
que des podcasts nuit suivant la place
toujours toujours avoir quelqu'un qui va
vouloir entendre parler plomberie
tout le temps tout l'automne puis ils
vont ils vont pas entendre parler
plomberie celui sans fil trouve sur
avec son sam
fake des packs astuces comme ça mais
après ça je pense que là on atterrit on
a atteint
la pleine capacité podcast au québec
podcasts des grand public je pense que
ce qui va se passer c'est qu'il le
public va tranquillement suivre je pense
qu'ils vont de plus en plus d'auditeurs
de podcasts qui vont découvrir les
podcasts qui vont se rendre compte que
c'est un média qui existe dans le vus
dans la surtout les derniers douze mois
le nombre des côtes en audio vraiment
augmenté je pense qu'il est beaucoup
plus de québécois rrq découvre les
podcasts commence à savoir c'est quoi ce
média le fait que je pense que
tranquillement le public voir rejoindre
l'offre mettons fait que va avoir
plus de monde qui vont écouter mais
paraissant imploser pas de gaz dans les
prochaines années
puis c'est ce que ça va fort c'est que
potentiellement les annonceurs vont
aussi rejoindre les podcasts aussi
trouvé que c'est une bonne piste de
solution mais bref tout ça pour dire que
je pense pas dedans je pense pas que
le monde du podcast va vraiment grossir
plus que cinq ans au québec je pense que
tu peux avoir plus de projets plus
vraiment plus ce projet ne tombe je
proteste en pense
je pense que c'est des trucs ainsi des
cycles comme n'importe quoi un genre
n'est pas que or un skyblog rester
l'athlète way fakty mettons les podcasts
à ce moment ci comme quelque chose qui
rend peu plus loin dans cinq ans avait
encore dans dix ans ça se peut qu'on
soit ailleurs fait que c'est dur d'avoir
un plan vraiment long terme du duo de
stars peur je pense que
on a un peu peur choix d'y aller genre
avec
au feeling attend de voir qu'est ce qui
se passe ou ça cerveau qui s'ajuste et
alexis en temps réel telus
peut-être que si ces autres choses nous
attristent us f je ne vois pas faire
autre chose
mais en ce moment c'est ceux ci et là on
est des nouveaux projets en parlait
il ya un nouveau projet avec alanis
comment serait rien sans rien
il arrive bien
qu'on a lancé la semaine passée
seulement connaissez mais on a d'autres
projets qui s'en viennent bientôt qui
sont vraiment excitant - parce que dieu
te parlais de podcasts niche
puis l'autre point
c'est des podcasts produit c'est que le
média podcast au québec on le connaît
quand tu dis pas de casse le monde pense
sous écoute le monde pense conversation
passe on s'assoit processeur 600 mhz est
exact au pilon nous on a nos premiers
projets
qui ressemblent à ceux peut pas on ne
peut pas vraiment parler plus que ce
bain on peut dire que ça avec quelqu'un
c'est un style de podcasts très
populaire ouais c'est le pack castrais
populaire quelqu'un qui est vraiment
plus la populaire danse tennis le
exemple les sherlock holmes découvrir en
un podcast qui demandait de la recherche
ouais qui demandent du montage puis on
va mettre la musique qui sait vraiment
plus
travailler huit épisodes de 30 à 40
minutes pis toi puis l'histoire une
histoire qui se raconte heures au cours
des épisodes puis
puis ça moi je vais quand même beaucoup
espoir que ça va trouver son public ce
potier cela je pense que ça va vraiment
être ça va vraiment être bon si on a les
premiers balbutiements on les a déjà là
on a déjà entendu le truc tu es puis
d'homme qui fait la musique originale
c'est vraiment ch c'est vraiment bon
puis l'équipe est vraiment forte fait
que ça va vraiment un coup le fait que
je pense que c'est une avenue qui
devient intéressante parce que le média
le médium du podcast devient une façon
de raconter une histoire qui en ce
moment c'est les les mini séries c'est
ce qu'ils peignent atv mettant le tdd
game of thrones eurinnov pas
ce genre de truc là et que je pense
vraiment que c'est une avenue qui
devient vraiment le fond à explorer puis
qu aux etats unis ont déjà commencé à le
faire puis une photo quand même au
québec on est tout le temps importe en
fait qu'il ya des jeux de bons qu'ils
font ici demain mais je pense avoir fait
ça c'est excitant ce kit ou six tentes
sont pas parler de ce que ça a été
annoncé
on produit ici un podcast de donjons
dragons way s'appelle voyais les gens
ouais il ya des jeunes paj instagram
palais les suit c'est une gamme qui nous
a approchés ils ont écrit pizzo ça
faisait longtemps qu'on en parle et
qu'on voulait faire un podcast donjons
dragons catalans si le studio excuse moi
je veux faire une parenthèse comme nancy
le studio on s'est dit aussi contrastée
mettons les grandes lignes de quel genre
d'affaires ça nous prendrait on avait
mal sans filtre évidemment on avait on
s'était dit on veut on veut produire
podcast de sexe on veut produire un
podcast donjons dragons on veut pas dire
un paquet de trucs rhein puis puis le
donjons dragons ont le ça fait longtemps
qu'on y pense et puis le sexe oral on le
way fait que le cse c'est ce qu'ils
feront un plus haut qu'on peut
comprendre aux phoques dont jean dragon
pis pour ceux qui connaissent vraiment
poste une vers le bas dans ta console de
jeux de table moi je ne pensais pas dans
le noyau grandeur nature avec des épées
en mousse la cccm stade mais quand même
il est apprécié
très belle table bing ptt rpg cinq
univers que
j'aime et on sait écouter sur un ring
fait longtemps que ça existe
incroyable pdpa de caste comme les
paquets sous ses ennemis qui fit plus un
show live mais qui en la version pas de
casteau six mois puis ça s'appelle c'est
incroyable c'est débile mantilles outre
s'il y en a plein c'est vraiment une
niche c'est quasiment la revanche des
geeks l'autre une sous culture qui comme
ses
bêtises parce que je pense qu'il ya
beaucoup de geeks dans le placard puis
moi je moi je suis j'en suis un de ses
grand grand grand geek pas
nécessairement dans le placard mais les
gens qui me suivent mettons en
superficie vont jamais sa mort sa grâce
à patrick lessard fois que je t'ai le
maître de jeu d'une game qu'on avait
coutume à l'époque des
faits et même toit le thé genre on n'a
pas assez longtemps à game et puis à
triper sur des affaires médiévale puis à
chanter du power metal
médiévale puis tout ce monde lui qui
sont quand même rendu dans trentaine qui
quand il était jeune il joue 2000
vingtaine début trentaine quand il était
jeune et jouer à ces jeux leurs antennes
ou un papy showa exact exactions mettons
le lui déconseille j'ai quitté jeunes
puis laisser comme les y est ils
triplent arqués genre c'est plus le son
n'est plus se cacher dans celle d'une
église pour jouer à ce fait bref ils
nous ont approchés au brochet piscine
gagne quand on étudie en théâtre
ensemble sur des acteurs puis sont
vraiment sacoches sont organisés sont
bons on motive et puis nous ont
approchés pour le fait on peut passer à
côté de ce projet le champion depuis ce
seul ceci étant dit si notre part en
tant que c'est pour les gens qui nous
écoutent un conseil de ville life the
voice
personnes me demandent et d'enfants mais
j'en fais quand - une lettre de
motivation le
spécifique à l'emploi que vous voulez
puis jeu pour la première personne qui
ne surmonte le julien juillet aaron de
believe supplément qui maintenant qu
avec un pick up il est dit dans son
podcast autrefois
si vous vous êtes la mer la personne la
plus qualifiée au monde que vous
m'envoyer votre cv sans l'aide de
présentation je louve même pas bref ce
n'était pas la première les premiers qui
nous écrivaient pour un projet de
donjons dragons mais c'était de loin à
la lecture du imelda proches les plus
près les plus sérieux piste est au vieux
crialese choc ouais c'était même pas un
dos tres noter on a lu le message puis
d'habitude ces messages d'autres
personnes qui veulent qu'on produise des
podcasts on en reçoit quand même
fréquemment battus dont les tchèques
puis c'est boboche comme comme message
c'est qu'on peut pas produire seul
héritier consanguins rapidement en
contre mais là cela mais je les cv j'ai
dit dom bad on lire ce message le talent
élire de faire toi même et cotillons du
monde à qui on veut le faire je pense
cependant les autres le gorille vraiment
fait que ça commence à moi bientôt fait
ça sent le 27 septembre
qui est
ça va vraiment et todd ça va être un
vidéo sur twitch au début ensuite voir
la version pas de casse qui va sortir je
pense à semaine après ça va vraiment
être je pense vraiment que
ça vaut quelque et mettons le monde qui
vont écouter suze mettons si vous
écoutez plus à l'écouté premier épisode
je pense de l'embarqué
si c'est comme disait tout des comédiens
qui ont toutes leurs personnages sont
bons et si c'est de l'impro il raconte
une histoire tabarka dedans puis ça
valait vraiment le coup c'est bien -3
puis l'a toujours dans cette affaire de
la pièce maîtresse est normal tout le
temps le maître de jeu le qui comme au
centre de ce c'est son univers c'est lui
qui parle le plus souvent c'est lui qui
joue tous les personnages qui sont pas
des personnages joués par les joueurs
puis joy et d'un croyez vraiment fort il
est vraiment forfait qui en avait honte
de vous et de vous montrer sur fait que
vision pas de 100 à 500 m et au moins
une vision d'un prochain demi
au départ le projet comme celui abordez
vous allez avoir beaucoup plus d'infos
très bien
cool fac et nautiques et sa
question épineuse question controversée
après ouais je pensé quoi de la cancel
culture ça je vous prêt à inviter
quelqu'un s'est fait casser ouais
une voisine si
j'allais juste j'arrive par une préface
en disant
faut faire attention quand qu'on dit
quelqu'un qui s'est fait kenzo quand tu
prends du recul mais tombe sur garde
l'ensemble des deux dernières années au
québec mais dont il n'y a vraiment pas
beaucoup de monde qui sont kenzy bat
parce que t'es pas qu'une seule tous les
pots c'est surtout prête beaucoup
qu'elle soit extrêmement
fatigué ou pas tout
puisque pitié 6 hip hop
c'est pas un panier dans lequel tout le
monde exact ce sens que la réponse à ces
questions le sait ça dépend ça dépend
qui ça dépend
quoi un pee toutes les histoires sont
différentes et toutes les histoires
doivent être jugés selon leur propre
mérite mais tombe sur leurs mérites mais
selon leurs propres ouais attribue la
pression à qui j'en sais peu tout qui
si je te penches d'en face c'est moins
c'est moins grave que si je te
fasse encore voir mon ami mais c'est le
poignard de l'avant
nous deux
[Rires]
ma vie c'est clair et oui c'est
ça dépend pas lafarge commence à
dépasser quoi que l'approché pis si
c'est combien de temps c'est quand même
une donnée importante important aussi
parce que le fait que la menthe diptyque
la personne a besoin d'un peu de temps
pour un petit break un petit break 6 mai
et après après tarbes at il eu le temps
de réagir à ces hôtels temps de changer
tout le temps de faire le tour de force
et puis
j'ai aussi le temps des événements ouais
tu mets ton kevin parent ans d'un bon
exemple de ce qu'est kevin parent moi
j'ai quand même je savais même pas qu'il
va recommencer à faire des shows mais
genre dû recommencer à faire des shows
le tpiy ce qui faisait des années qu'il
y avait 25 ans genre je comprends ces
bad rites et gâvres ci était car en
crise le genre peut faire des choses
philippe se sont enfin s'il va faire un
show mettons les gens sont libres de
venir ou poney après ces émeutes ont ils
dit
des fois c'est différent lançant ce qui
m'est on te fait jouer une toune à radio
bleu et écoutent la radio tard soit peu
choix changer de poste métier métiers
aller voir un show mettons
les gens sont capables de jeu même si
c'est sur toute la sphère de cet épatant
claude cancès et qu'il faut une autorité
suprême qui décident baissé de 0,6 mais
toi à justifier une autorité sur une
autorité s'ils allaient le système de
justice mais je dois là dedans c'est
comme s'il y en a peu ces cinq ans d'un
collectif c'est un réseau
[Musique]
fixe genre
fax et l'allemagne sont capables de
prendre une décision selon les
informations il aurait exactement pim
est tombé le jeu des mois qu'il fallait
encore inquiète fire celle de sa soeur
qui se fait et betty
je dois demander me faire rembourser mes
billet si c'est comme ça que je me sens
même temps pas d'aller voir parce que
puis je le droit d'aller voir ce jeu les
bosquets
c'est sûr ça va affecter en crise
l'heure tourne et c'est sûr que de monde
qui vont se faire rembourser et qui
remplit le ayant pas nous les retournant
parce que soit un trop de monde au fait
si j'avais pu y aller ou deux les
promoteurs en fait tu es en fait une
offre le fais ce que tu as pris à partie
a dit moi je me retire du tour
m'est et
chacun est juge de prendre la décision
qui veut utile pour répondre à la
question si nous on juge qu' on est à
l'aise à savoir quelqu'un qui sait les
anguilles mais casey
bell va le faire mais loin
encore
vraiment pense pas parce que ce serait
pas que cette entame et on peut rajouter
le crucifix et ceux qui partent en
voyage défense on sait mais on ne sut
jamais dit je pense encore une fois même
que c'est quand même
ya eu des
îles et des
éclaboussures de tous les côtés le site
web avec toutes ses toiles de cfi
amnistie comme
c'était comme rendu à un point où est ce
que
tu avais été un des cas amener tu avais
été bad a mené le 6 août avait fait un
mauvaise décision ait pris une mauvaise
décision au lendemain puis le faut que
tu perdes doute là dessus puis
évidemment que six affaires là on peut
durer évidemment que ça peut marcher
genre les espèces de courant de faire
perdre courtiers ont le camp c'est lourd
à l'anis avec son histoire de l'élevage
ce mal est fait la page heinz harald
frentzen foule c'était terrible c'était
quelqu'un faisait une erreur puis
fallait chanter en public mais non de
15,6 euros puis un versement après ça je
pense que aussi
du monde qui ont qui n'ont pas eu la
main qui sont pas tendres les cracks qui
aurait peut-être dû perdre des
privilèges qu'avant mais je pense juste
que chaque personne prend ta propre
décision le sueur sur la personne puis
après sedan les critiques et des gens
qui encouragent des des personnes que
toi tu aimerais pas encourager
ces acteurs regardent pauvreté c'est ça
la fin tu prends ta propre décision pose
et sédition là au monde le 6 titres
c'est ce exact mais imposer sa propre
décision en étant
mais depuis le web acle mots depuis
mettons le documentaire michael jackson
-
je n'ai pas vraiment écouté ni pitié ça
parce que pour moi que l'action sera
associé à ce j'ai plaisir à écouter ce
jeu juste pas dire que
ça va mais dans ma tête moi je lis quand
c'est l'été dans ma tête à moi c'est ma
décision mais tu deviens aucune station
devient pas une sainte je fais pas
délecté des lettres ouvertes puis des
pétitions chaque fois qu'une saison de
radio fait jouer michael jackson parce
que s'il y en a d'autres quant à l'aise
avec le fait d'écouter je la dessine
aussi sa part sympa tout à toute
décision est prise ça oui parce que oui
effectivement il ya plein de monde qui a
pris ma décision puis d'autres qui ont
pris nos décisions
seul sens fait sens ce
fait que
petit dernière wallonie pendulo ces deux
dernières ont mis en commun qui est
présent non
car apparaître les podcasts des nique et
claudia sur la médecine et qui est l
heure on aurait pu lui demander comment
dizaine équipe à l'heure américaine a
enregistré en affaire aussi un
chéque seul jeu dans un autre
puis je me sens pas d'autorité
desserrement de la river vice pipec
prenez un vraiment prenez le laisser le
psy vous si vous dites que vous voulez
faire quelque chose
la fenêtre d'opportunité plus le seul
mais je suis de penser à ça parce que
parce qu'ils y ont enregistré à peu près
je sais pas combien d'épisodes de
podcasts les genres sortez le font
sortir les utilise pas casser l'aspect
longtemps mais au moins ils l'ont fait
ils y ont pris les mesures puis ont
repris
mais c'est parce que je parlais de ce
aussi avec le game a appelé tout à
l'heure puis il m'a demandé c'est quoi
mon conseil met donc je n'aurai aux gens
les psys juste de faire les enfants
faites le si vous avez une idée
maintenant le
à les îles puis ça va pas être bon début
ça sera jamais bon au début j m il rien
vous allez frère qui va être parfait au
début je vous donne un exemple j'ai fait
imprimer
des sacs pour le picard endurance plus
avec la caféine démarquer caféine de f1
sur mon sac qui la financent francis et
un ans marqué qu'à fennecs de f1
français c'est pas parfait maintenant
packaging et une faute de français
dessus mais tabac c'est coûte trop cher
trop cher tu peux pas faire réimprimer
se fait que je les vendais qu'une faute
de france heymans mon sac puis le monde
ils ont compris mes erreurs le tia
personne qui a fait c'était pas parfait
fait que le boycott ces genres tout le
monde toutes les commentaires depuis que
100% des commentaires c'est positif 5
étoiles ce genre c'est fou le j'ai fait
une erreur mais ça fait chier là j'ai vu
mon sac j'ai fait fort
c'est chiant sauf que si j'avais attendu
main d'abord le sac parfait je l'aurais
pas fait c'est la même chose dans toutes
on l'a déjà dit pour le sans filtre
c'était pas bon au début mais on n'était
pas bons le site et on avait des bons
invités fécond ont sauvé la mise
mais ce type quelqu'un mettons le si on
n'avait pas su éviter le pote le podcast
au début aurait jamais levé 6 mois
maintenant j'avais pas une tribune qui
j'avais là on avait la chance que
conçoivent des injustices et comme on
n'était pas bons le palais n'était pas
sur le cresson la fête le ti qui a mis
du temps mais lyon peut etre des
meilleurs puis on était encore loin
d'être parfait sauf que on est pas mal
plus à la haye ce qu'on était
initialement puis
nicky nicole
il ça fait longtemps ce projet le pis il
l'a en fait on commence à enregistrer
mais le sortez le sortir mais au moins
le font au moins de temps il faut sauf
que il faut
pour le sortir faut le sortir faut
sortir il faut faire ses enfants le plus
longtemps atteint avant de faire ton
affaire le plus gros savoir dans tu as
trahi le plus sale bien et n'ont même
plus des crises mais le fait du pauvre
et gratuitement réfléchir l'autre ma
pensée j'avais la conversion aussi avec
mon ami plaisir à me disais tu sais pas
où tu commences mettons quand tu veux
lancer un truc mais même tu commence par
faire la première étape tout cas qu'on a
commencé à pour penser au studio le on a
pas faire du genre voici tout
l'équipement que ça nous prend voici
combien ça coûte voici jol le plan
officiel ne fait ça nous prendrait selon
le prix qu'on est revenue au studio qui
on ne faisait que mls a voulu prendre et
ce plus à chaque étape mangiapan le coup
de plus le cas dans ce cas sa part le
faire commencer ce concours est un
marathon qu'ils commencent à courir
comme ça que c'est ce mauvais cap du
photomarathon laissés sur qu'est ce qui
vous amène les 42 kilomètres devant toi
sale irene scène et semaine par le
premier ne commence pas le
premier kilo le
suspens sera au deuxième assaut je pense
qu'au troisième il yad'autres qui m'a
écrit l'autre jour parce qu'il voulait
qu'on travaille ensemble sur sa musique
albigeois a quittés mais dangereux sur
les compagnes que je réalise son projet
puis à ce moment j'étais en mode refuser
tout apport à moins que ça soit la chose
la grisaille j'ai juste pas le tente
juste le temps qu'il faut j'ai des trucs
sur lesquels je
jeu que je moi je refais faut que je
fasse de la place pour se
croire mais j'ai du temps le ti dans le
sens pas prêt c ontre succès contre du
temps puis
puis
c'est ce genre de match et l'ex le fait
que ces 80 du temps écrit moitié et j'ai
dit non même fait le genre sur un
concert donné fait le attend pas
vraiment être à peu près rien trouve
quelqu'un qui dise polo hofer ce après
comment faire mais lens 3-1 food france
- ce que les celts maintenant ou jamais
mais toujours maintenant jamais c'est
toujours maintenant ou jamais pour
n'importe quel projet n'importe quel
plein match où tu veux partir un blog
mais
des bouftons par s'était passionnée par
la bouffe puis ça fait longtemps que des
j'aimerais sommes partis sur un blog
quand tes amis te parle de crise est bon
bien combien chez vous mais tu dois
partir un blog que j'aimerais ça
j'aimerais vraiment ce thème reste à
hauteville francs parce que si tu
aimerais sur puis c'est juste mc penser
que si tu veux le faire fait la main aux
débuter les soldes vont pas et au delà
de ça va être l'être n'ont pas la bonne
came retard après bonn lafarge prend pas
des bonnes photos fait l'homme a mené
doit prendre les bonnes photos père mené
ça va être cool par année si c'est un
projet qui passionne
ça va arriver
c'est sa main sa technique est
celle à deux jours enfin 31 ans ouais
si
en fait au début de l'année 2022
12 janvier
je cherche et qui sait comment j'avais
quand j'ai commencé à écrire dans un
journal
[Rires]
ouais
puis
d'impressionner ouais
si
j'avais plus je vois qu amy tu as
quelque chose ce que tu entends plus
utiliser ce métier à la question où on
pas tant amusé
j'ai comme j'avais comme le goût de
commencer à écrire mais aussi de ses
idées qu'on s'écrire dé tourner vers aix
puis ensuite
c'est ce que je me dis juste commencé
par écrire en mode fruits et flou pour
juste comme être capable que d'ouvrir
les cabales qu'avant que ça sonne après
ceux où si tu réfléchis une phase avec
le panier des idées là dedans pour le
transformer sans texte justement j'avais
comme continue d'écrire je cause de
commencer à composer des toons mais sans
paroles
que finalement ils risquent d'arriver et
puis le genre
wang lequan hadopi le genre jeu culte
alors que j'ai dit oui au truc que je ne
pouvais pas refuser mois avec le sas a
appris le sahb ribas et puis
le jour de mes trente et un à deux jours
j'ai écrit mon premier texte de tourner
mais tant
pis logique composent une petite taille
sera composé a tout compris la toune pas
mais ce qui s'est effectivement que le
type il j'ai même fait un petit est un
petit pays que le tipi juste enregistré
peut-être pis pour probablement que
c'est le
ver propre peut-être par jour
mais rien n'y fit et wii puis le jaraaf
a redonné la première médecin men cim et
on tue prend en considération que
soit améliorée à écrire des toons puis à
composer des tonnes à la même vitesse
que tu t'es amélioré pour produire de la
musique parce que moi je me rappelle
quand qu'on produit des beats au début
quand commencer à produire les dents le
seul chez des parents puis qu'on
écoutait ce recteur puis que l'on écoute
mettons ce que tes gars là de faire en
production de musique on est des petits
tout ce qui est musique al genre s'il
pensait le trouver des mélodies trouver
des était composé de la musique et ça
fait 14 ans chez exact mais c'est écrit
des textes parlés les laisser les
grilles large différents genres c'est
notre faute - avec lui j'ai commencé à
explorer ces attaques et peut-être qu'à
man et ça peut sortir
les
sacs et accessoires si comme tu sais
j'ai rangé je me sens crise comment ce
que j'ai commencé cette démarche leur
mettons
le 2 janvier puisqu'elle c'est le jour
de ma fête que je continue psicom
clamence mirador quelque chose dans le
le changement d'année me dis qu'ils
soient cosmique ou personnel qui comme
un week end l'état avance noms du web
wem j'ai joué
c'est comme si on veut pas manquer tant
bien que franz b match à la grande
famille de manquer de ta
fac et
[Musique]
[Rires]
pour nous en parler
derrière ce
retour des podcasts chaque semaine une
question qui nous a demandé ça
moi ce moment mais je peux de réviser à
quoi il peut arriver n'avoir que moi ce
moment ça ban a donné que ce soit
si on est des conversations en le
faudrait et et que je voudrais leur
guise en mode mais le fou je l'allaité
en fin de mois puis soit si sûr parce
que ça fait quand même une qui a fait
une espèce qui à chaque semaine c'est
comme on est tout le temps et de
l'argent c'est comme planifié les
prochains fatah recherche pour les
prochains
c'est le tourner fils était c'était tout
le temps ça tout le temps c'est l'homme
faut deux semaines
c'est easy way c'est comme on vient ici
tendance en clair qu'on a pas juste se
piquer son sac large de lui on y goûte
pour un bon témoin mais ça peut être le
fun c'est si tu vas faire de même c'est
cool si ceci si des affaires comme ça
maintenant aussi décliné membres parce
qu'on est juste nous deux une c'est
quelque chose qui vous intéressent la
ceni le savoir pour rennes reçoit
écrivez-nous sur instagram ou ou d'un
commentaire sur youtube ou à l'éleveur
parce que c'est sûr que se sait moins
c'est moins impliqué oui puis la cité
autant que toi que moi je pense qu'on
commence à voir la broue dans le toupet
est depuis un bon petit boulot puis je
pense pas que tu penses pas moins non
plus que très en verve en ce moment leur
tomber at il faudrait que l'incitatif en
soit
c'est grand
c'est comme mon emploi ou vous qu'on
souhaite maintenant qu'on concon frapin
compagne un deal que ce soit genre et le
ligotent et
mettons vous allez sa vie un peu plus
votre job et on parce que pour le studio
tales sans fil c'est quand même c'est un
peut vraiment en parallèle du studio
s'est pas vraiment je considère pas ça
fait partie de notre job au studio
maintenant puis il faudrait que ça
devienne un peu une partie de notre job
parce qu'on a menée dit-il le nombre
d'heures dans une journée et quand même
restreint le pis il faut être capable de
le justifier dans notre corps est
maintenant au delà de juste un projet de
club ça en restera toujours en est un
mais s'il ya une raison qui fait qu'on
est capable de le justifier plus
dans le proverbe un pas que pixel compte
pour s'arranger pour le justifier plus
mais pour l'instant je pense que c'est
good ba oui pitié si vous voulez écouter
d'autres podcast il vend la mort il y en
a beaucoup de fair use idiotie en
appelant ses pyjamas comme ça fait
longtemps qu'on fait c'est aussi
pitoyable et discussions des comme
quelque chose qu'on a fait un qu'on a
fait et c'est exactement ce que je pense
que ni toi ni moi s'intéresse de comme
refaire et encore et encore la même
chose
fact et la question de abrite deux cent
dix épisodes de wassit sud est où ça
vole sans filtre pis c'est quoi être
action comprend comment qu'on kunduz au
thon on reste
la date et puis je veux pas aussi
titiller je dirais télé youtube the
young and
on a tout le temps un peu de volume pour
jouer la game puis les fois qu'on le
fait on a eu on s'est fait des meetings
en interne rapidement pour dire qu'on
n'était pas nécessairement l'ajax et se
mettront des extraits clips bate on en a
déjà fait puis rapidement au début du
semble même pas après même pas un an je
pense qu'on s'est aussi regarder en
streaming pas vraiment ce que l'on veux
tu que j'ai rempli pour que ça marche
fort qu'en france pour ça il faut que tu
joues la game c'est sur ce genre et on
aurait pu être crissement plus agressif
sur genre est justement faire des gros
clubs batterie prend des trucs hors
contexte politique d'accords contexte on
faire des affaires et puis on n'a jamais
voulu faire ses excuses on n'est pas les
excès de poids tomber leurs potes le
podcast ou de l'exact contraire combler
l'ancien podcast d'abord que toutes les
affaires sont dans leur contexte exemple
sackey sa saison - ouais mais
effectivement c'est un bon point ce que
tu dis parce que je me rappelle vraiment
qu'on a déjà parlé le cas qu'on vous
pensé arrêter le sans fil
quand on avait dressé la liste mettons
des personnes qu'on voulait recevoir
la liste soit du monde qu'on avait déjà
reçus soit du monde qui nous avaient dit
non ou soit du monde à qui on avait déjà
écrit
fait genre
il y avait plus personne à aller il va
falloir tourner
vers recevoir des gens réécrire et
insisté sur d'autres personnes ce qui se
passait
cette game boy afin d'étayer pas de
nouveau par quatre en existe qui
fonctionne folle bien coin mais moi je
me dis mais ton je me verrais pas faire
face je me verrais vraiment pas faire ce
qu'ils ont fait
ouais je réponds à ma grosse face
maintenant à un montage rapide des
jarrets punch il
se
dit l'artiste sélectionné d'aujourd'hui
qui aurait aujourd'hui encore une fois
de ce nouvel os vous aimez ce parce que
sur ce genre d'affaires qu'on peut faire
c'est le fun c'est le fun c'est le fun
des questions qui sont
sur beaucoup de questions tu y mets ton
par rapport aux podcasts et moi votre
invité précipite à tout prix éviter la
mauvaise question le team et mettant vos
invités préférez vous pourquoi j'ai
décidé par un panier c'est comme
s'écoule métier béton des questions
comme on dit aujourd'hui des politiques
plus écouté sur n'importe quoi c'est le
fun de sortir juste parlé pas juste de
parler de podcasts 4 on parle pas de
calais d'autres choses ok merci à vous
écouter c'était toujours le pied on
faisait ça lui gagne approchèrent ne
vous oublie pas nous oublie pas non
jamais